[Music]
three
two
one
upload
i notice you're really lonely and sad
and you often express your feelings as
anger
you helen
welcome to upload your digital afterlife
uploads live a life of luxury pleasure
but they laugh something that makes
death worth living
prototypes
congrats mommy
welcome back norah anthony thanks it's
been a long time
i got so much to tell you we have an
extremely difficult camera let me speak
to a manager
what seems to be the problem you're a
[ __ ] you've been cheating now cheating
on me ingrid gave up everything and
uploaded for me i'm with someone too
i've been cheating on cheating on you oh
it's all good brother
that was weird so weird
uploading should be accessible for
everyone we need to hold the greedy
powerful people accountable
he likes bloody mary's and the rollback
of environmental laws
well
we can handle one of those this
we're taking this place over wow
thank you place your bets
you can listen in on any upload
do me
oh my god look at her she's so beautiful
anything else about me you were
considering bicep inflation a little
bigger
just a little more
perfect
it's so ridiculous
[Music]
you